hello and welcome back to the shitty
science show in this video we'll ask the
question
superheroes may be fiction but is there
a future for super foods so this video
is actually for the representation of an
essay rate for that a young writer
nature essay competition my essay didn't
win or anything like that
but it was kind of referenced in one of
their summaries so thought that it would
make a good video nonetheless so you can
actually read my entry here but in this
video are pretty much just speak for it
and also go into a bit more detail about
synthetic biology alright so here it
goes
now those of you familiar with one of my
favorite scenes from the 2000 film Miss
Congeniality will surely remember how
Cheryl misinterprets this question what
is your perfect dates the thing is I
would say well I probably wouldn't but
for the purpose of this I would but
anyway my perfect date would be fresh
with a soft and chewy texture yes in my
case I referred to the fruits and
apologies it's actually quite hard to
draw with limited colors for not only do
dates
taste goods they also have a great
biochemical composition of essential
vitamins minerals dietary fiber
carbohydrates phenolic acids and court
annoyed with the antioxidant
anti-inflammatory and anti-cancer
properties this conversation as thoughts
provides they are often considered as
superfoods a marketing term for foods
that provide health benefits due to the
high nutrient density and so eating
so-called superfoods has become
desirable for extending one's health
span disease-free lifespan especially
since aging is a major risk factor for
cancer cardiovascular and
neurodegenerative diseases targeting
Aging three diets would therefore be an
effective strategy to minimize the
incidence of multi morbidities and
likely be a cheaper alternative than
treating the diseases individually
helping to reduce health care costs as
the global
increases in house ban continued to lag
lifespan our superfoods the solution to
prevent this addition
lifetime spent on morbidity well the
problem is there is no scientifically
agreed definition for our superfoods
neither is the term commonly used by
scientists and dietitians this is partly
due to a lack of scientific evidence
supporting their health claims but also
because superfoods individually cannot
substitute a healthy lifestyle
and balanced diets but what if effective
superfoods could be created there not
only provide nutritional value but are
accessible to everyone ensuring food
security in an environmentally friendly
manner with the global population
predicted to exceed nine point six
billion by 2050 doubling crop demands
and estimates of up to 20% of late life
spent in mobility developing a superfood
would be a desirable goal but is it
attainable within my lifetime I just
adds the idea of it being within my
lifetime was one of the requirements of
the essay competition redefining the
superfoods the Kohn so-called superfoods
gained their title from the both of its
men's minerals and chemicals they
possess which claim to reduce blood
pressure and cancer risk redefining
superfoods as health spine enhances
would require the addition and tinkering
of crop components to achieve this
followed by substantial testing of their
efficacy to gain scientific approval
much hype is currently surrounding a
variety of drugs that are beneficial to
extending lifespan and/or health span in
various species these include drugs like
metformin which is currently registered
for clinical trials against age in
itself resveratrol spermidine and
Reformation the latter three are
produced naturally from different
biological sources but incorporating
them into the synthesis of edible crops
simultaneously at various concentrations
or using chemical derivatives of the
drugs or novel drugs yet to be
discovered was enabled the crops to be
distinguished from currently available
superfoods regardless of the contents
they these crops would have to grow fast
even in limiting conditions to meet the
demands of the global population
estimates and thus showing Abrial SiC
and biotic stress resistance this is all
to avoid the fruit system placing a
major toll on land-use biodiversity
action freshwater usage and pollution
from fertilizers which are major
contributors to climate change how could
this idea then be turned into a reality
improvements and year with quality and
stress resistance have already been
achieved in crops using genome editing
this involves identifying genes
contributing to these traits and
mutating them accordingly CRISPR cast
gene editing systems have the potential
to advance the pace of targeted
modifications and incorporates foreign
gene clusters for the synthesis of the
science gene clusters for the synthesis
of natural drugs like resveratrol can be
sought from the original species from
which they were discovered whilst
metformin would require ingenuity to
modify the synthesis pathways of related
natural chemicals modifications of this
sort would bring superfoods into the
realms of synthetic biology and yes I do
know how to spell synthetic and
synthetic biology is the application of
biology and engineering to design and
produce novel biological components in
this case novel regulatory genes are
kits for the biosynthesis of the
selected drugs into crops more gene in
clusters are likely to be discovered
through genome mining ventures and
high-throughput sequencing to explore
the fast amount of biochemistry out
there but regardless of the methods
international corporation for superfood
production would take time their
European Union currently treats
genetically modified crops with the same
stringent regulations as genetically
modified organisms this would limit the
planting and selling of the crops and
investment opportunities for research
and development so why should we care
aging and sustaining the planets that we
live on affects all of us this includes
the future generations to come if aging
can be targeted in a way that also deals
with the competing battle between crop
production and climate change it should
be a high priority goal to strive
towards sure there are many logistics to
tackle how to gain research funds for
developing crops I don't find drugs to
enhance health span and their effective
and safe doses through clinical trials
how to incorporate the drugs into edible
crops organizing international
discussions on the ethics of using
CRISPR and how to regulate
accessibility of the super foods to
everyone but we have the tools to get
started but at the break free comes on
the 24th of April or another future date
within my lifetime
super foods congenial for health and the
planet would benefit all of us so that's
as the end of my essay but just because
it's pretty interesting and part of my
title I just going to slight bit more
detail into synthetic biology and so
obviously my essay was a bit type that's
cool but this recent nature a few
article actually goes into some examples
where we have seen improvements and
achievements being made with the use of
synthetic biology already and they've
really emphasized the point that with
synthetic biology we can try and achieve
the biology of Botha's not there so you
know evolution so nice like to say many
genes and proteins we can you know take
that knowledge and then transform it and
prove upon its modify its and the size
about sustainability by design is pretty
cool and so yeah definitely go read that
I also like the way that they flipped
Richard Feynman's quoits what side units
understands I cannot use to create very
true in the case of synthetic biology
see ya thanks for listening to my essay
and they have a good day